philipp es gibt offenbar auch immer mehr
berichte darüber dass es freiwillige
gibt die an die front wollen
richtig es gibt viele berichte über
ausländische freiwillige die in die
ukraine reisen um an der front zu
kämpfen selensky zufolge sind das glaube
ich mehrere tausend menschen vielleicht
bis zu 16.000 sogar haben die u keiner
gesagt diese zahl könnte natürlich etwas
übertrieben sein aber ja wir haben hier
auch schon als solche männer getroffen
da sind meistens ex-soldaten die
entweder wirklich der ukraine unbedingt
helfen wollen in diesem angriffskrieg
gegen putin es sind natürlich auch und
diese menschen werden nun mal vom krieg
angezogen etwas abgehalfterte gestalten
die es vielleicht schwer haben nach
ihren militärdienst und jetzt entweder
einen adrenalinschub oder geld brauchen
und deswegen vielen reisen und eine ganz
besondere rolle sollen ja auch
mittlerweile die frauen in lemberg
spielen die die soldaten unterstützen
absolut also gestern bei hier frauentag
auch wie überall auf der welt und diese
lemberger frauen haben ihnen begangen
indem sie einfach alles getan haben um
den militär zu helfen ich war mit meinem
kollegen til biermann hier in einem
zentrum wo sultan netze hergestellt
wurden militärisches gerät
beispielsweise um das inntal damit man
das aus der luft nicht erkennt andere
frauen zum beispiel großmütter stehen
den restaurants in den hinterzimmern und
füllen essen abfüllen essenspakete ab
für die soldaten etwa an der front oder
hier in der gegend und lemberg natürlich
auch ganz viele männer und frauen sind
um die stadt zu verteidigen im ernstfall
verlegt du bist ja nicht nur unser
reporter vor ort dort in lemberg sondern
auch unser chef kommentator hierbei
bilden gestern war annalena baerbock die
deutsche außenministerin bei uns im
studio wir wollen mal ein paar ihrer
kernaussagen zusammen analysieren
gehören mal kurz rein mit blick auf die
nukleare frage ist es ja so diese waffen
strahlen auch zurück und die ukraine ist
direktes nachbarland von russland wir
arbeiten gerade mit hochdruck daran weil
wir auch noch atomkraftwerke in der
region haben dazu eine vereinbarung zu
finden
über die in nationale atombehörde
sicherzustellen dass diese
atomkraftwerke nicht beschossen werden
dass es dort nicht noch zu einem
desaster kommt das heißt auf allen
kanälen sind wir unterwegs weil die
situation einfach so ist das wir erleben
müssen das tagtägliche schlimmeres
passiert wie soll man so etwas sicher
stellen philipp wir bekommen heute
morgen berichteten dass beispielsweise
der kontakt nach tschernobyl abgerissen
ist die internationale energie
aufsichtsbehörde hat im moment überhaupt
gar keine angaben mehr darüber wie die
situation vor ort ist
ja ich glaube das zeigt wie gefährlich
dieser konflikt ist nicht nur für die
ukraine sondern für europa und ich
glaube man kommt derzeit mit
verhandlungen mit putin nicht so weit
man muss einfach den druck erhöhen und
frau berbalk hat ja auch gesagt mit
allem was man hat muss man den druck
erhöhen und dazu zählt auch natürlich
mehr waffen zu liefern sowie das
beispielsweise die polen gemacht habe
denn man kann gute ihn jetzt anrufen und
sagen hey du das mit den atomkraftwerken
das gefährdet uns alle das gefährt auch
euch aber das ist diesen diktator
einfach egal er versteht nur eine
sprache das ist die stärke das ist die
sprache der stärke des drucks und das
musste jetzt anwenden philipp gehören in
eine weitere aussage von annalena
baerbock rein da geht es um die
historische verantwortung
und das ist auch unsere historische
verantwortung gerade aus einem land
heraus nach dem zweiten weltkrieg nach
dem schlimmsten gräueltaten sich die
menschheit darauf verständigt hat zu
sagen wir schaffen eine institution wir
schaffen verträge die ebenso einen
angriffskrieg als völkerrechtswidrig
einstufen wir schützen menschenrechte
weltweit und deswegen auch bei der
wortwahl ich glaube es ist wahnsinnig
wichtig jetzt nicht dass putins narrativ
die erzählung die propaganda auch noch
zu wiederholen zu sagen auch die
vereinten nationen sind ja irgendwie
schwach und hilflos nein diese vereinten
nationen haben gerade diesen russischen
präsidenten klar und deutlich gesagt du
stehst ganz alleine in der welt für
diesen krieg haben außer russland nur
noch belarus
syrien eritrea und nordkorea gestimmten
andere diktaturen haben nur noch dafür
gestimmt und das hat deutlich gemacht
russland ist isoliert und deswegen ist
es mir auch so wichtig dass wir die
vereinten nationen unterstützen
in der tat philipp fast 150 länder von
200 haben eine resolution gegen putin
unterstützt andererseits das bedeutet am
ende nichts für ihn
ja völlig richtig also die resolution
wurde verabschiedet der krieg geht
weiter
deutschland ist ein land das sehr stolz
ist auf seine lehren gezogen hat aus dem
zweiten weltkrieg man hört immer wieder
in den sonntagsreden der politiker nie
wieder
wehret den anfängen und ich glaube wir
sehen gerade dass putin über das stadium
des anfangs deutlich hinaus ist also
wenn das nie wieder etwas wert ist dann
muss man glaube ich den druck dramatisch
erhöhen derzeit ist die situation so
dass wir immer noch russisches gas
kaufen und aus diesen einnahmen
bezahltes putin die bomben die
afghanische zivilisten abwirbt ich
glaube nicht dass das dieses handeln mit
historischer verantwortung gemeint ist
deswegen glaube ich ist noch deutlich
luft nach oben für die bundesregierung
philipp du bist in lemberg für uns nach
wie vor ja wie ist die situation heute
wie es vor allem die flüchtlingslager
momentan im westen des landes der
ukraine
ja ihr habt vollen darüber gesprochen
dass heute nacht menschen evakuiert
werden konnten aus zu mir ich aber
gerade mit einer flüchtlingsfamilie
gesprochen die auf dem weg ist nach
lemberg alle die irgendwie raus kommen
aus den umkämpften städten in der
ukraine kommt erstmal nach lemberg
dementsprechend geht es dieser stadt der
bürgermeister von lemberg andrej story
hat gestern schon gesagt diese stadt
platzt aus allen nähten wir können nicht
allen helfen wir brauchen viel mehr
unterstützung das große problem ist
natürlich einfach platz denn hier kommen
jeden tag zehntausende menschen an die
zumindest eine nacht irgendwo bleiben
müssen viele von diesen menschen sagen
einfach am bahnhof und das mittlerweile
zuständig immer nur schwer ertragen kann
man muss sich ja nur mal vorstellen wenn
in einer bahnhofshalle tage lang
menschen aus und zwar tausende menschen
dass man sich kaum bewegen kann also die
sanitären an
ich schlafe das ist alles das große
problem hier in lemberg und es ist auch
leider kein ende in sicht weil guten ja
einfach weiter boomt
philipp lemberg freut sich schon sagen
ein schlüssiges philippi edwin lemberg
ganz herzlichen dank philipp